hi it's rich isin show Chris Mannix
Sports Illustrated filling in for rich
rich we back tomorrow jetting back from
London the private DirecTV jet is
somewhere over Arkansas it is here it
will be landing sometime in the next 12
hours sitting here now though rosh mark
aziz senior columnist / or senior
columnist he's kind of the senior class
covered a great column on the chargers I
want to get into with you a little bit
later on but columnist LA Times all
right so I want talks of basketball with
a first it's great to see LA relevance
it's been a while been a while it's been
a while I mean I feel the way about New
York having lived there and you live
there as well but Knicks have been like
decades of irrelevance now you have two
teams in LA that are both high-level at
least look high level and relevant but
the better of the two teams right now
the team that you would predict to go
further in the playoffs right now would
be which Clippers and Lakers I thought
Clippers at the beginning of the season
just because I I knew how some of those
guys fit together and I kind of sensed
how Kauai and Paul George would fit on
this team I did not foresee how quickly
the Lakers would gel the LeBron and
healthy Davis dynamic Dwight Howard
playing well and we'll see how long that
lasts
they've really played well and I really
caution people that first game of the
season they were like oh like look at
the Clippers I said that first of all
the Clippers I think are they're gonna
be the best team in the league and the
Lakers are right behind them so I really
do believe and I know we've talked about
this before I think those are the top
two teams in the league and I and I
think we're gonna see for the first time
a hallway series which we have not seen
here before okay can you just pump the
brakes
Lakers Twitter hates me almost as much
as Knicks Twitter last season because
you were the first guy that I remember
that I that you said they're not gonna
make the playoffs and I still think if
they were healthy they would they want
to make the player the person I remember
saying you're like the magic make the
play yes that cliche about shoes like
you don't think this team is out there
for sure gonna make the playoffs right
and we we kind of chatted about it media
day and then one of the things the clip
that went out there we talked about this
in the first hour that went kind of
quasi viral on me was me saying that the
the Lakers have a better chance of
missing the playoffs and winning a
championship I still think that's true
because I can't get fully invested in
this Laker team when two of their wins
have come against Charlotte and Memphis
no no don't look at the wins but just
look at how they're playing like does it
look like this could be a a championship
contending team and I think if you just
watch them play they're a championship
contending team I think if LeBron gets
the playoffs you can't bet against exact
like you know LeBron in the postseason
is still the scariest player out there I
know Kawhi Leonard has proven himself to
be a great postseason player but LeBron
in a seven-game series I'm not betting
against I should see what talent around
him but Chris we've talked about this I
am fascinated by the Dwight Howard
because for the first time in his career
he's really being told this is your role
he's not being brought in to be like you
could be the star like there's no chance
of him being a star on this team he has
a specific role he has embraced that
role and he's played really well I mean
he's giving them exactly what they need
he has played exceptionally well for
most of the start of the season and I
will admit if this continues I was dead
wrong
on Dwight Howard yeah because most of
the league - most of the league but it
was an earned distinction 102 years ago
or so when was he in Charlotte was it
two years ago so I mean he's played with
six teams in six years I know it seems
he hasn't played for like like Adam for
a split second Memphis just bought him
out but he was in Charlotte and he
played 81 games that year and he
averaged 16 and 12 he was three years
ago averaged 16 and 12 and he had one
team that won to sign the Washington
Wizards
they wanted to sign him like you are
still like was it late tweet early 30s
let's say when he was in Charlotte maybe
even late 20s and you averaged 16 and 12
like take the name Dwight Howard away
from it 16 and 12 over 81 games you're
getting like a max contract from some
teams and you want the Wizards out there
being like you know do we want to
guarantee the second year do we want
Golden State before they got to Marcus
cousins they're like they kick the tires
on that yeah we're good we're taking the
the cousins guy from Sacramento has got
the blown Achilles like we're gonna go
with that guy I mean I just I'm stunned
by by how well Dwight Howard is played
you know the book on him a rush and how
much
what you found in talking to people but
when he was in Charlotte it wasn't so
much like he's this cancer and he shows
up late and he do all this
it was the passive-aggressive stuff it
was like the occasional weird locker
room speech where he tried to be a
leader it was it was on the floor on the
floor it was like you know he doesn't
get a touch from Kemba Walker and he's
putting his face in his jersey lotions
and then as one coach down there told me
he's like the play calls for a pick and
roll he picks and pops and shoots his
broke bleep jump shot yeah like that was
the line from the coach that I talk to
you down there so it was it was little
things that bothered people but he seems
to he is for the first time practicing
what he preached exactly and for him to
get a non guarantee contract for them to
basically say we're gonna bring you in
last chance Corral if you don't make it
like you're done and he's really
embraced that role and again I mean the
first time here it's like night and day
that relationship he had with Kobe was
terrible just for the the examples you
brought I mean when I heard when he was
being recruited to come back and they
were like well Kobe's gonna be the me
I'm like oh he's gonna be in the meeting
so it's it's good to see you want to see
players like that do well and so I'm
very happy for Dwight you sat down with
Kobe recently a column there what does
Kobe see now about that relationship he
realizes that it was just a bad fit at
that time but he's happy for him and he
realizes that like certain guys need to
be me he basically had it if the Lakers
did not sign him Chris and you know this
he may not be in the league so when
you're in that position you kind of had
that moment of clarity where you're like
okay all that stuff I did before like I
got a stop it so like the things that
people don't like about me as much as
that still me I can't do that and this
is my role so he's happy for him
you know Kobe's just kind of he's doing
his own thing and but yeah I think I
think he realizes that was a bad fit at
a really bad time I still think a rush
that we're talking to Rosh marcozzi LA
Times columnist joining us here Rich
Eisen show I do think that the Lakers
for them to be successful Anthony Davis
has to play Center like 75% of the time
and that's especially true with Kyle
Kuzma
now back in the lineup their best lineup
to me is Davis LeBron Kuzma in that
frontcourt and fill in the blanks at the
backcourt positions Danny Green of
course in somebody else what do you
think I mean he's date yeah
Davis is notoriously reluctant to be a
five-minute so here's that you're not
gonna start him at center you're not
gonna call him
he's Center you're basically gonna pull
him aside and say you're gonna play
Center you know so for whatever reason
he doesn't want to be known as the
center so listen when you have that big
you know you know when we named the
starting lineup and you're like
introduced you're not the center but Dan
theny when we are in this position to
close out a game you're gonna be playing
that position same with LeBron at point
guard he's not gonna start at point
guard he's gonna play point guard yeah I
mean he's gonna be the primary ball I do
miss Rondo in a lot of basketball i.q is
through the charts and having another
playmaker out there is smart I am happy
for for go-to Clippers I'm very happy to
see Frank Vogel gets kind of the
positive attention he deserves I have
been riding the Frank Vogel train is a
good coach I think he's fought been he's
much more of the coach we saw in Indiana
that led the Pacers to back-to-back
Conference Finals then the coach we saw
over to dysfunctional years in Orlando
this is a good basketball coach that if
you listen to him and you buy into what
he's saying he will not steer you in a
wrong direction so one thing that I said
I said it's a popularity contest in Los
Angeles and everyone like loved Luke
because of but the thing about Luke is
that he's not quite a great coach and I
said with Frank Vogel you're getting a
fantastic experienced coach so
regardless of what they brought in in
terms of players just having Frank Vogel
as your coach this season is huge
yeah no question before we get to the
Clippers specifically on Kawhi Leonard
it was last June I think that Doc Rivers
made some comments about Kawhi being you
know analogous to Michael Jordan the NBA
find him $50,000 for those comments
Kawhi after the game yesterday was asked
about those comments that Doc Rivers
made here was his what he said listen to
this Kawhi I don't know if you heard
over the summer doc
Rajon like Michael Jordan that question
came up today I just mentioned how just
the similarity between your game you
heard about that Colin back in the
summer was your reaction to sort of that
comparison you that yeah remember it
okay goes before the summertime
is one of my friends reason for the
reaction network oh really
you know I just ran over to those in
playoffs is locked in but you know I
mean just be able to you know get
recognized for my talent so you know
where I came $50,000 doctor was mine for
that best $50,000 ever that's been spent
Steve Ballmer would have paid 20 times
that if the end result was what happened
to wanted because that clearly resonated
with why Leonard listen he loved what
that team provided in talking to doc
about that if sort of that Steve Ballmer
Jerry West Doc Rivers he wanted to play
for a coach that he respected and he
respected doc and he respects what they
were doing with the Clippers and he
wanted to do his own thing I talked to
Kobe about this and he said listen it
wasn't a knock on LeBron or the Lakers
he wanted his own team he wanted to do
his own thing and so listen the way he's
playing right now in the way I mean
people forget they still got a top 10
player Paul George covered all this team
and Chris this is where it's gonna be
big I think on most nights you don't
have to have two of those guys you can
do load management in a creative way if
you have a back-to-back where play Paul
one night said kowai kowai one night you
know you can get creative and listen
it's all about June in Toronto prove
that and I'm sorry for the league
because they hate to hear it but the
success Toronto had with load management
that's the trend 60 games work why last
year or something like that I think the
Raptors 17 and five in the games they
play without it was good for them to
kind of get that type of ability to play
without him but I think it's incredible
seeing I think what Kawhi is gonna be
able to do once Paul George comes back
defensive versatility that that team is
gonna have is really something we're
joined by rosh mark Ozzy columnist LA
Times joining us here on the Rich Eisen
show let's talk football for a minute
the Chargers win they beat Green Bay
convincing win great win maybe the best
of the season so far
and I love your colleague Blaschke use
the opportunity to have a big Chargers
win to say get that team
here that team doesn't belong here are
we now even the short time is this city
ever going to embrace the LA Chargers or
is just the Rams and nobody else the the
problem with the charges is we always
view them and you just had this mistake
is the San Diego Chargers and they're so
close to the first time the shiny like
fischels have made that mistakes
play-by-play
play ball so they were so close that
Chris if I wanted to see a Chargers game
it was a two-hour drive so it wasn't
like we needed them to move here the
problem is Qualcomm was not a pro
football stadium anymore it was you know
they needed a new facility and in this
day and age if you don't get public the
public to help you out with that and I
don't agree with that but I'm just
saying you're not gonna keep a team
there so unless they find a way to build
them a brand new stadium in San Diego or
somewhere else they're not gonna move
because the quite frankly a few miles
away from your Chris they're building a
five billion dollar stadium and they're
gonna move in there and they're gonna
play and unless someone can build them a
new stadium they're not gonna move
here's the thing too you can't judge a
team like the Chargers or the Rams or
any team that parachutes into a market
for a generation guys yes you need the
three and four year olds who don't know
anything about San Diego that grow up
thinking the lightning bolt is cool and
Phillip Rivers is great and Melvin
Gordon is fun and Bose is cool to watch
you need those kids to become charger
fans to have their parents take them to
games and eventually themselves buy
tickets and merchandise and become real
charger for use an example bill plash he
came to our high school and I wrote
about this column so he talked to our
high school about what is it like
growing up in a Los Angeles without pro
Football and we're like we're fine we
got the Lakers we got the Dodgers we're
totally fine
so for 21 years I grew up in a Los
Angeles without pro football and now you
got two teams here and they expect us to
be hardcore fans the cheapest ticket for
Sunday was $300 the only people buying
that ticket are hardcore Green Bay
Packers fans there are not hardcore Los
Angeles charger fans yet now it's like
the nets and when they parachuted into
Brooklyn from New Jersey I mean that was
just what an hour or so away from where
they played but you're not gonna get no
New York fans to embrace your team until
you grow a generation exactly
it's just just the way it is ah before
let you go give you a lot of grief at
all times but you had a cool video
without Schwartz I'd ask you about this
I mean you were doing an interview with
Arnold I mean you know you and I have
been friends for a long time you've lost
over a hundred pounds what last year
when tell by the Arnold story because
you sat down with them and what happened
well so I sit down with them and they
only told me like listen you only have a
you know ten minutes and so I start
recording I'm gonna make it quick and he
goes before we start I want to
congratulate you and I said well thank
but for what like I'm like looking
around like he probably thinks I'm
someone else for losing over a hundred
pounds he knew my story he knew that I
got on a plane I couldn't get the seat
belt to fit I got on the scale it was
320 he knew my story that I had tweeted
about I haven't written that story yet
so it was surreal it he's like we got to
tell your story in hustle and fitness
and I thought he was joking last week
Chris muscle fitness calls me up so I'm
gonna be a bustle of it we're just sorry
I mean the whole thing is incredible but
it is a testament that if you just
decide one day and I know it's not
simple because for 15 years I let myself
go if you decide every day I'm gonna
work out 60 minutes a day I'm gonna do
something I'm gonna watch what I eat you
can do it and for like Carlos
Schwarzenegger I mean the for him to
know my story is still surreal what's
the muscle fitness story gonna be well
so his point was like like that story is
a great story like you're not you don't
have a six-pack or anything yet but that
you could decide one day that I'm gonna
take care of myself and then I'm gonna
do car you I'm gonna live some ways I'm
gonna just try to change my life and he
said that's a good story you don't have
to be the strongest man in the world to
be in that magazine and so I thought it
was nice of him to say I thought it was
a compliment and I moved on with my life
and then I get a call from Muscle &
Fitness that we want you at the magazine
[Music]
that's right airbrush that's something
by the way Arnold we were talking
earlier about you know movies you get
mileage out of like how many much more
mileage are not getting on the term yet
19 million and he was in like half the
he's gonna like in
it's awesome I'm with you in fact I mean
I know some people that saw like the
Celtics went to a screening of and they
really liked it it was fun players I
mean that's I was like one of those guys
like he'll be in like terminator hospice
movies till the very end like it's same
thing like Bruce Willis entire like
wanna see we were talking about the
roasts of Bruce Willis I think it was
Jeff Ross it said I look forward to your
next die hard movie die hard six natural
causes like that is last movie very cool
to see to see that good for you man
every day because I see your Instagram
out they try to do it drive me through
walls because I can't give me a lot of
grief and I workout today I don't want
to forget it in school what I did before
and listen I've done this for like a
year but in previous times like I've
worked out for a week and then I've just
stopped I don't want to I want to do
something I enlisted in a course of a
day you have 60 minutes you have 20
minutes to do something and so the cool
thing is whether it's you or someone
else saying like good job and that
encouragement Schwarzenegger to give me
that encouragement like I'm gonna keep
going that would send me right to rush
le times great work at the Times you're
right what twice a week now is that
three times a Sunday must tax your
considerable talents always appreciate
you coming in my friend enjoy the bar
mitzva late appreciated a little bit
later on coming up on 40 minutes past
the hour this is the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app